you
they are installed era at 4% Tierra
histogram nerves various tricks
banksters economies metal Scott till
Alfred Nobel's me man
satin continent cos auntie Liu Lu Jia du
pre does very sick spank conscious
economic a memoir sulphate novel it is a
great honor to introduce the laureates
of the 36 Bank Prize in Economic
Sciences in memory of Alfred Nobel
professor Shaw tickle
thank you your Majesty's Royal
Highnesses ladies and gentlemen the
great economist John Maynard Keynes once
wrote if economies could manage to get
themselves sort of as humble competent
people on the level with dentists that
will be splendid 83 years and much
research later we will perhaps aspire to
be compared with meteorologists or
doctors whose scientific accomplishments
have been truly outstanding and yet
after faced challenges that are rather
down-to-earth a failure to foresee or
prevent the financial crisis is a sore
reminder of the dangers of her breast
true enough we had to work on most of
its ingredients but like a virus that
keeps mutating new dangers emerge when
we thought we had it understood and
avoided the existing ones the need to be
humble also applies to the field that
was rewarded by the price recognizing
that industries are different from each
other and evolve rapidly researchers in
the industrial organization have
patiently built a body of knowledge that
has air preg you laters to better
understand market power and the effects
of policy interventions and help firms
to formulate their strategies they are
thereby contributing to making this
world a better place The Economist first
mission yet there's so much we still
have to learn and the world changes
faster that our understanding can keep
up ways humility is not easy to preserve
when receiving such a prestigious award
Albert Camus in his acceptance speech
wonder alley rich only knees doubts and
his work still in progress
could cope with being at the center of a
glaring light his answer was that he
could not live without his heart the
great French scientists of epoch away
describes the unmatched pleasure of
discovery so it is only a flash in the
middle of a long night but this flash
means everything wisdom therefore
encourages me to return as soon as
possible to my lab to the colleagues to
Imam indebted for this prize in short to
the wonderful life of a researcher but I
shall be profoundly and permanently
grateful to the committee for the
immense honor it has bestowed upon me
and to the Noble Foundation in Sweden
for their astounding mission of drawing
attention to science
year after year on behalf of all this
year's low rate I would like to propose
a toast in the owner of Arts and
Sciences skal
you